ANITIN OUR HEALT
A MAJOR ANNOUNCEMEUSO THAT SHOUD
ISG IT STATES.TECOENCD
THEYCOMMEN THOSE
VIRUS TRANSMISSION
WHO ARE FULLY WE ADO TWO
ALL U.S. COUNTIES ARE IDR SUBSTN
SOES TSCHOOLS.
THE CDYSLL  S
WHO A
WEAR .
HERE'S THE CDC
MOMENT A
>> THED OF CD VELAACCINA
RATES AND INED
THT AN IMPORTALY
THE CI ILLNESS,
SUFFERING, AND DEATH C AVOIDEDHR
VACCINATIOCO IN TH
COUNTRY.
'SNEW CDC GUIDS A RECT RESULT OE
ED IN THC SAID WERE NECESSARY T.
WITH THE HIGHLBLE AND EVEN MOR
TRANSMISSIBLE LIESNDS T THE
CCINE BEIN ALLVER ND OTHSES NS
AT AN ALARMING RATE,S ES NOWTS.
>> WITH NES
INIONS RISING VERY IS REVISING S
MA GR VACCINATED
PEOPLE IN AREAS  SAYS HAVE OL V
TRSION.
NOW REENDING THEY WEAR MASKSLIS.
>> IN RAREASNS VACCINITH
THE DELTAFR MAY BES
AND SPREAD THE VIROT. NS WORRISO
>> THE
COUNTRY LIVES IN A COUNTY WITHN
LIVES IN AOUNTY WITH HIGH
TRINEVN KA ANDD NEARLY EVERYRI,A
NG I
TIME.
>> AR CDOR
HIN ANOTHER FOUR
S LIKEF OUR TRAJECTORY
IS S IN THE UNIT
KINGDOM THAT WE COUL
MANY AS 200,000 CAA   CURRENT R.
r:
RE0000.  ONE DAY W IACCORDING T
THREE MONTHS.HIGHES
>> THE KEY HERE IS .
PROBLEM, A  THOSE ELICCINHAVE E
ERPANDEMIC. W
THE
HODOANWE VARUSE THE O SOMEBODY E
MUTATION, ANTHADE.orter:TIONS
NGLY IN LESS
STATES.
FLORIDA, ONE OF THREE STATES
LEADINNATIONW COVID
CASES PER NOW ACUN
>> V.ATRE UNY S.OF ORANGE COUNT.
ACK TO
VACCINE MAES.SAYING JUST A E O L
EMPLOYEES IS UNDER
CONSIDERATION.
ISY AFR HI
VA HLTE OST HEALTHCARE
RKAT THE
>> RAT, NT OF VETERANS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
T'IN'S
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJA
I'M VACCIN I NEED TO
WEAR A
>>H- RIGHT.
IF YOU LK  THA IF WE
CAN PUT THAT MAP BACK  AGAIN.
WHAT WE'RE TALNG HERE IS
AREAS WHERE THE VIRUS ISTI
, AS IS
OUT, DS MODERATE.
THISS  CONFUSE
PEMOT, T SPEAKING
ACCORDING TO THIS NEW IDIN D.C.R
VACCINATEO PUBLIC PACES.
YOU'REATA SO WHYYOHE RED
NEED T --
>> THIS IS WHAT THEY'RG 'VE KNO
FOR SOME TIME
RATES AREN'T WHERE THESH
WEE  E DELTA T HAS BECOME
DOMINANT.T GENO IS YOURTION.
PERSON WHO DEVELOPS AN ICALLY SD
OUIO SO-CA
RRHE SAME RA,
R NOSE
WHO IS
CARRY THE SAME AMOUNT
OF VIRUS.
VACCIN  NOT MEAN THAT THAT
S NONE G ELSE IS SORT OF F E
IT STIEALLY WELL AT EPING THAT .
D THEY STILLNS
IT'S POSSI WALENSKY IS OUT, THIT
IT'S RARE BECAUSE THE
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS AREN
FSTOU
NOT SOMETHING THAT WOUAPUENTLY.
BUT I THINK ASS GO
WE'RING INTO THE FALL, I
THINK THEYHEY
UCIS INDOOR ED MASKING AGAIN TO
>> SO,N WORDS, YOU ARE
IN AN AREA THAT'S RED,TL
GEORGIA.
YOU ARE VACCAT THE
MUCH THAT YOU'RE GOINGO YOE
BENEFIT OF OTHEREOPLE.>> CORREC.
THEY ARE ALL JUST AT THE AGE NOW
HOUSEHOLD OR WORK  A WHO ME ATE
NG O
ABOUT
TH
THIS SHOULD NOT SUGGEST, AGAIN,
ON'T WORK.Y COMFORTABLE
NOT GOING TOERY  EVE
IF I DO DEVELOP SOME SYMPTBUT WH
JAKE, ACCORDING TOR. WALENSKY,
T BASICA FOUNDCE TY THAT EVE Y
DEVEL O
N UNVACCINATED INFEC W. FOR CHI
URGING EVERYONE,
FACULTY, STAFF, IN K-12 SCHOOLS,
TO WEAR A MASK IN SCHOOL AND CDI
ONIT
L SYSTEMS EXPECTED
GBOARD WITH
K
THIS IS GOING  MAKR SOMEVERY, Y.
OUSLY SERA
DISTRICTS AROUND COUNTRY
AVE LAWS THAT PREN
MANDATES.
THEY'V THOSE.OL DISTRICTS IN NE
N RETURNING WITH
I KNOW HERE INC
OLAS WELL.
GOING TTHE COUNTRY.
WHAT WE ARE REPORTING RIGHT NO
JAKE, IS
HOCHS THIS NEWUI
AFFECT THOSE SCHOOL
THERE L THAT S ON THE FENCE ABON
TODAY.
SO, THIS MAYHEM  INT WEARING.